he is entering his 14th year
in the national football league the 2008
draft choice
out of boston college of the atlanta
falcons joining us here
on this may day on the rich eisen show
matt ryan how are you matt
rich i'm doing great thanks for having
me on always a pleasure to have you
on so um what what is a may
mid-may day in 2021 look like for you
right now matt ah it's pretty nice here
in georgia okay weather's good
good start i had uh a little workout
this morning
on the field with the with the team uh
you know going through some of the new
systems throwing a little bit this
morning
and then uh some some virtual meetings
this afternoon so
uh not a bad little not a bad little
tuesday
so what is it like um learning something
new-ish what is it like having a new
coach new
system being brought in in a way what do
you got for me on that
that's exciting you know and and i think
newish is probably the right way to put
it i think there is
uh you know some some carryover from
some offensive systems that that i've
been in the past uh arthur
smith has has worked with you know matt
lafleur who was
obviously here as a quarterback coach
for us in 2015 and 16 but
he also worked with mike malarkey and
terry rubiski uh which were two guys
that
you know were here mike was my first
offense coordinator in the league and
terry was wide receiver coach here for
you know eight years with me and so uh
two guys that i know well
so there's there's a lot of kind of um
a carryover between multiple systems
that that i've played in
uh throughout my career so there is a
lot uh
in here with which you're already
familiar or is being kept in because
you're familiar with it
and this is your um offense for the
atlanta falcons
moving forward here it's
there's definitely some new things some
some things that uh are are different
for sure
and the terminology is a little bit
different but uh
at some point you know there's
a lot of people do a lot of the same
things and so you're just trying to
translate
uh you know concepts that you've run
before into new names and making sure
you know it and uh
it's been fun though it's uh i think at
this point in your career the longer you
get
a little bit of of a jolt of new and a
little bit of
having to work on things that kind of
invigorates you and gets you going this
time of the year matt ryan here on the
rich eisen show
you mentioned a jolt of something new um
and yet
uh the word jolt could have been a
completely different
ball of wax had the fourth overall pick
been somebody other than kyle pitts who
i want to get to
in a moment um where did you watch the
draft
matt ryan where did you watch that walk
me through your draft night
it was not that exciting
just at home so it came off we put the
kids down
we've got twin boys put them down and i
watched just just my wife and i so it
was low-key
um but yeah
not not a great story behind it just on
the couch like everybody else watching
uh on a thursday night but i think you
you're you're a smart man you know where
i'm i'm driving out here
did you know going into that night it
was going to be kyle pitts did they clue
you in
at all on what was going to happen draft
night atop the draft
matt ryan no not really you know i i
i think they were up front the entire
time uh right from the start as they
were with
with all of our players uh you know
saying that
they're going to evaluate this draft
find the player that they think
is you know the the best fit and and
the best for us moving forward uh and
it's your responsibility as players
regardless of who we draft to go show us
that you're the right person
you know for the position and so uh i
think i was treated the exact same as
as everybody else in our building um you
know but i was
certainly excited when when it was kyle
there's not about that right uh
and fired up that he was gonna be a part
of our building so um
again communication and this is what i
find so fascinating about your
scenario and situation for the lack of
better
uh terms matt ryan is you know there is
another
mvp quarterback um sitting up
in wisconsin and we are all consumed by
what may be going on
between him and the front office because
the communication apparently was not
there
for him on a draft night in 2020
and so what what else can you tell me
about the communication that was between
arthur smith terry fontenot maybe even
arthur blank and you rich mckay and you
to make sure that you were clued in as
much as possible so they
you understood what was happening here
with you having a a window of
opportunity left in the league
that's on the back nine if you will
matt what can you share about that yeah
i think
you know i i think they were all open
and honest
you know all for those people that you
mentioned and and they said listen we
haven't made any decisions but
we're we feel like we're going to draft
this person and
uh that that is the best player
available for us at this spot
and whether that's quarterback whether
it's defensive player whether it's tight
end whatever that may be
you know that's what we're going to do
but there is also you know communication
that
we believe that that you can play for us
uh we're excited about that
and and so you know while it's not
always
necessarily exactly what you want to
hear uh from coaches i think
as long as they're up front with you to
me that's always been
you know all you can really ask for it
and you know i've been very lucky in my
career to always have that here in
atlanta
and that hasn't changed with uh new
regime coming in i think they're very
open
and up front with me and i appreciated
that right from the start yeah i mean
arthur smith and the two times i've
interviewed him
strikes me as there's there's no smoke
and mirrors like literally he's
it's right there on his sleeve on his
chest in his mouth
and what comes out but that's what
struck me a couple times i'd never
interviewed him before he became the
head coach of the atlanta falcons matt
yeah
he he strikes me very much the same way
and i appreciate that i think
you know i think you appreciate it more
too the longer you've been around the
older you get
just just be up front with me you know
and and
uh and i think those guys and arthur
blank and our entire organization has
done that
you know has done that for me but i i
think he's
really consistent with all the players
right now and uh that's something that
you know i i think you get on our zoom
meetings and you get a feel for
for how things are going to be run and i
think that's very much
uh the point he is getting across so
when kyle pitts gets drafted your
what was your what was your dre like if
we had a camera on your draft
your draft home scene with you and your
wife what would
what would you have seen once kyle pitts
got drafted matt
i think my wife was more fired up to me
sarah was ready to go uh you know
yeah it might have been next split over
something like that i don't know what
let's
uh but it was uh we i mean obviously
excited in
in in those situations you know i've
been in that situation
too and uh you know where you're up
there at the draft i was in new york and
um you know you know it's such a game
changer for for that kid who's getting
drafted and what their night looks like
and what you know next week and so uh
you're excited for him but also
selfishly you're excited to
to add a you know hopefully a a great
player for us that
um you know can can help us win games
here so
matt ryan here on the rich eisen show
you said you just done some throwing
have you thrown to him yet
have you seen him i have yes what's that
what i mean
everybody keeps saying that he is just a
matchup nightmare does not actually do
justice what he does
or what he looks like what he can do
what about from your point of view
matt ryan well you know i've been lucky
i've played with
i've played with some some really good
players you know in my career
and the consistency i would say that he
has to some of these really good players
is that he's eager to learn and he wants
to do it right and
and he's and he's wired in that way and
to me
obviously his skill set is incredibly
impressive you know that's why he was
drafted fourth and
you know you can see that just from
watching him play in college i mean it's
it's impressive but i think the thing
that that fires me up is
you know he's he's he's locked in
he's engaged you know when he's out
there on the field when it's time to
work he's ready to go
uh and that's a similar quality that
that all the really good players that
i've been around in my career have had
and so
that gives him a chance uh he's got a
long way to go there's no question about
that but
he's got the right mindset the the right
kind of energy
and uh mental energy that i think it
takes to to be
really good in this way no and i look i
i know he's just a rookie and i know
you've thrown to tony gonzalez so
and i know those are two essentially for
the position of tight end maybe the two
polar opposites
on the spectrum you can possibly get
between rookie and
and and tg so yeah i think it's it's
just hard to put an expectation on
somebody
right uh i like that and and and the the
message that i'll
always hammer home to him is not about
you know
how gifted tony was i mean he's
incredibly gifted
unbelievable uh but how he worked
what the day-to-day was like why he was
good you know that that's
those are the things that you know i
feel like i can help them with moving
forward
having been around guys like that that
were so consistent
week in and week out you know what their
practice routine looked like how they
got themselves ready to go how they took
care of themselves
those are always the things you know
that that that i'll be able to
you know pass along and connect him with
tony and that that'll be things that
that will help him be more consistent as
he moves forward
no doubt and then at whiteout julio
jones calvin ridley you and
kyle pitz together i mean have you just
even for a moment thought
um are you driving in the car or just a
quiet moment my gosh
this is this is amazing potentially what
i've got here
uh set up for me um as i'm getting
during year 14 of my nfl career
no doubt you're you know really
appreciative of of
you know where i'm at going into year 14
the guys i have around me
um you know this is that's what you
dream of as a player
you want to play with great players you
want to be on great teams you want to do
those kind of things we've got a long
way to go to get there
and we got a lot of things that that you
know it takes more than
than just a you know a couple of guys on
the outside to win football games we got
a lot of things that that we've got to
do to get better
uh but we certainly have some pieces uh
that fire me up
and uh you know i'm excited about that
well you know what i mean
if in case you want to have a shorthand
for it uh matt and
you know it's you and calvin and julio
and
kyle pitts um i think you should just
refer to yourselves as the
pitstastic four
what do you think matt you're the king
of you're the king of coming out with
perfect knickknacks
i do have a reputation um you're being
too nice certainly no don't stop
be quiet you may not churn it
i've been cultivating this caper stop it
i even have uh i i even had my crew
mock up uh a comic book cover matt
there it is on the screen uh all four of
you
on the heads of the fantastic four um
you can't i gotta see this i gotta see
this i gotta get a tape of this i'm on
the phone right now
i understand that trust me matt it's
coming your way um
but just so you understand um
kyle pitts is mr fantastic because he
can stretch
defenses with his amazing catch radius
and incredible wingspan
uh julio jones is the human torch
because he can fly down the field and
burn
secondaries all day long the invisible
man is calvin ridley because he can
disappear from
from a defensive back site right off the
line only to reappear
with the ball in the end zone and uh you
are
the thing uh matt because your
stone-like skin makes you resistant to
blitzes and
perfectly reasonable nickname
suggestions
so wow that's the picture
do you really though dude please tell me
this is important do you like it i gotta
see the graphic
i don't have the graphics well just me
i've considered that you'll see the
graphic first but
i'll be honest with you you sound like
you've given us quite a bit of thought
a lot a lot more than the max a lot more
than the natural i've got nothing better
to do
matt it's mid-may you know what i'm
saying
yes but the area the pitstastic four
it's got a ring to it i'm just saying
ah well done thank you that's all i'm
looking for
that's all i'm looking for i told my
wife i was gonna do this she goes please
don't do it
[Laughter]
yes my wife's from the boston area you
know like and she's
she's got the lfg in her too and she's
just yeah she's telling me no but
i'm i only know one speed speaking of
which um
did you see michael vick did you see
michael vick running a 40-yard dash
of uh four seven and change at age four
flat for him yeah mike mike only knows
one speed two
all gas all gas he uh he can still move
that was impressive to see that
just yeah so what was your 40 time back
in the day
did you run one i was it was never four
seven i know that much
i think the best i ever did was like
four eight nine something like that just
under four nines
which i was pretty proud of you should
be wow chris is that the one
nailed it four eight nine matt ryan matt
there you go that's a never forget you
never forget that one time you broke
four nine
isn't that amazing it's just 1 100th of
a second but 489 sounds so much faster
than 49 flat
it really does work that way 100 100
hey matt thanks for the time really
appreciate you every time you call into
the show
and uh let's do it during training camp
and before again your 14th season in the
nfl
uh um i appreciate the time thank you
sounds good rich look forward to
connecting then
that's it that's matt ryan m underscore
ryan 02 on twitter
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here